growing your own vegetables
even in the most forgiving of climates
is a challenge that many of us are all
too familiar with
but for svalbard's residents polar sun
cycles that see
months of total darkness in winter and
midnight sun in summer make conventional
farming here
near impossible
[Music]
what's happening now we're all kind of
disconnected and that's what i've been
trying to do is reconnect everybody back
to
to where the food comes from because we
all take it for granted you know
good morning
have some greens for you
some radish for you
and some clover uh we started to
plant your other one so it's once it's
ready then we will start to follow that
but for now we have
this so this is amazing yeah and the
other ones are there i can take the
voice
thank you thank you long travel
distances for food or for waste disposal
of almost 1 000 kilometers between the
svarbar city of long yibian
and the norwegian mainland mean that
residents here are some of the world's
highest energy consumers
recognising a lack of available fresh
local food international chef turned
longy been local
benjamin vidmar saw an opportunity to
change the way that food was viewed
so we started this in 2016.
and we ordered it from alaska this dome
and then we put it back together
and we had to put a lot of concrete
around the perimeter so secure to
concrete
here we focus more to the leafy greens
herbs we do some micro greens
now we have some beets there there's
kale yep
radish daikon radish so yeah we've just
been growing
what we can grow and these kind of like
the cold weather so we don't have to
warm it too much we know we don't use
any
heat inside of here it's only from the
sun so it can get up to 30 degrees when
the sun is out and it can go down to 5
10 degrees when the sun's not out now
it's about 8 degrees in here
and and this dome is only used in the in
the summertime when yeah only when we
have light
so from end of may to about end of
september
we can grow out here and then the rest
of the time we grow indoors
fantastic and leafy greens you've found
to be
the most kind of i suppose for your
system
the most kind of economically viable to
keep this to keep this operation running
yeah well the thing is it would be so
nice to grow tomatoes and cucumbers and
potatoes but we wouldn't make much money
from that so
and all of this stuff comes by flight so
it's very expensive
to buy and it doesn't transport very
well so so that's why we've been kind of
focused on that yeah
sure using two main facilities
benjamin and his team are able to grow
in both the summer and darker winter
months by working around seasonality
benjamin uses both indoor and outdoor
facilities in order to maximize his
productivity
while minimizing any waste and energy
consumption
so i normally just go through and open
everything up
this is radish the daikon radish
this is also more radish
you managing all of these and the mirror
because yeah
he's uh he's the we're the main two
behind i just need to water these
but i we're the main ones behind it so
like i kind of take over the greens
and you know keep them growing and he
does the delivery
and he also takes care of the basil
and things like things like composting
you mentioned that you're using compost
from yours and other businesses
uh have you seen it kind of rise at all
in that since you've been
i actually don't want it to rise no
because we don't have the
space or the facilities to deal with it
so now we only compost
what we deliver yeah yeah sure so when
this goes out
we take it back but if you are upscaling
then we would take more
yeah for sure we would take more because
we would need to but for now it's very
small scale
but the thing is we make the possibility
for our guests to compost who else is
doing that
yeah everybody else throws it down the
drain or they throw it in a garbage so
so it's nobody else doing that
so tomorrow i will take this one maybe
this one this one and this one and i
will put under the light
and then it takes about another three
days and then we can deliver it okay
yeah
what does the light do for them uh it's
going to turn them green because now you
see they're a big yellow okay
longy bin's busy restaurant industry has
absolutely welcomed a new option in
ben's locally produced greens
high-end restaurants like funkenlodge
now use ben's home-grown ingredients to
give their dishes a unique
arctic edge my name is jelena
i'm working at the svalbard
funken lodge for six months now
oh it's what you get from the ships i
mean
this is amazing yeah especially i mean
we are almost at the north pole yeah
so this is exclusive i would say
for uh for svalbard and also it's
sustainable and it's really cool i mean
you don't even have this like in
gothenburg where i'm from
yeah i mean if you don't have fresh
things
you can never make good food
according to me tastes better yeah and
of course i mean we grow it
here so it's always fresh if we order
from the mainland and it goes by plane
it's also bad for the environment and
also it usually just dies
on the way here so it's just bad and we
need to throw it away anyways
so it would be best for everyone and for
svalbard's restaurant in general if we
could grow as much as possible here
so hopefully we'll get there so i mean
we're on a good way
outside of growing vegetables ben also
operates tours of the local area in his
custom-built restaurant on wheels
it gives guests a unique insight into
his operation as well as a chance to
experience local foods like arctic
reindeer
paired with his very own greens
[Music]
yeah so it's a restaurant bus and we
have uh we do tours
we do the arctic topper tour we do
northern lights tour so you sit in there
you can drink wine we serve some snacks
and then it's the kitchen is on the side
of it so the kitchen is like a food
truck
and then the bus is like the restaurant
and you serve your produce and stuff
yeah that's the plan now we want to make
like a
set up where we grow our food we serve
it with our tours and yeah i can show
you around if you want to have a quick
look
so once we get a piece of land we will
park the bus we will park the kitchen we
will move the dome
set it up there we're going to buy a new
greenhouse that's like a hybrid system
that
it's uh in the summer it we use it has
like a reflective flap so we open and we
can use the sunlight
and then in the winter we close it and
we use lights so i don't want to use
electricity all year i want it to be
smart
so when we have sun we're going to use
sun and when we don't have sun then we
will use electricity
although it has taken ben a considerable
amount of time and energy to gain
support for his project
local perceptions about growing are
slowly changing
so what do you think about you think
it's worth trying to grow vegetables
here versus shipping immune from the
mainland
yeah definitely it's a
step in the right direction to become
more sustainable
so it's cool a cool thought
i think people also worry about the
environmental footprint that we
make who are living here would be nice
to reduce that
since we've been doing this there's been
so many unintended consequences now
everybody's trying to grow food and
everybody's
inspired to do something different and
they're all growing based when they're
all sharing pictures of it and
the university of tromso people came
here and like they're like all
phds and professors and this and that
and they came here and they said wow
he can do this we can do so now they
want to set up some growing stuff in
trump so they're so they're going to
name it after me as well so
this little project is inspiring so many
other people making people think
you know that it's possible you know you
don't have to wait for
what are we waiting for that's the thing
what are we waiting for we need to we
need to do it now so
that's what we're doing we're working to
do it now
you